l'ampleur le score n'est pas la hauteur
de nos attentes effectivement mais je
suis je suis convaincu que ce soir c'est
pas là la défaite de la droite
c'est la défaite peut être d'une
candidate qu'il n'a pas réussi à
imprimer les messages qu'elle qu'elle
portait durant cette campagne qui a été
quand même assez inédite dans son format
avec des causes qui ont empêché le débat
démocratique et je pense qu'on paye cela
avec sans doute aussi un vote utile
le vis-à-vis vis-à-vis d emmanuel macron
mais peu importe
encore une fois les républicains sont
sont une famille politique qui ont
marqué l'histoire de la vème république
sous différentes formes je pense encore
et républicains ont un avenir est ce que
les républicains sont unis aujourd'hui
quand on voit effectivement valérie
pécresse qui appelle qui dit kiki
qu'elle votera donc fort emmanuel macron
eric ciotti qui dit ce soir qu'il ne
donnera pas de consigne de vote écoutez
ya un bureau politique demain midi on va
discuter de cela quelle est notre
position vous savez on a pendant des
semaines des mois on a convaincu les
électeurs que valérie pécresse les
républicains et la république en marche
ce n'était pas la même chose
donc ça veut dire quelque chose je pense
que la droite à un courant porté à des
valeurs a réaffirmé à oser d'être de
droite à être fier d'être de droite et
c'est tout cela qu'on va discuter demain
pour avoir une une ligne politique très
claire et des consignes très claires
mais là encore je pense que
la période des consignes est derrière
nous à nul n'est propriétaire des voix
des électeurs c'est à 2 e de juger pour
le second tour nous on à se reconstruire
par rapport à une ligne politique très
claire est de droite et une droite
affirme précisément mais ce sera ma
dernière question 1 valérie pécresse
selon nos dernières estimations et qu'en
dessous des 5% est ce que c'est un
problème d'incarnation ou deux lignes
politiques vous dit fièrement il ya eu
un problème de ligne politique quels ont
été les offres qui ont été commises non
écoutés à il faut il faut reposer les
choses est ce que notre parti est fait
pour organiser des primaires tous les
cinq ans je sais mon intime conviction
là-dessus problème c'est la primaire
c'est la primaire et c'est aussi le
choix d'une ligne politique vous savez
quand nicolas sarkozy en 2004 fin 2004 a
pris le parti il a mis deux ans à
obtenir une ligne politique à travers 18
conventions et le corpus idéologique de
la droite doit se reconstruire à travers
une seule ligne et derrière je pense que
le chef de parti doit incarner
l'alternance pour 2027 et l'avenir ce
sera avec qui selon vous écoutez ça ça
sera je pense aux partisans aux
adhérents des républicains d'en juger
mais mais là encore
il ya de l'intelligence il ya énormément
de talent je pense à laurent wauquiez je
pense à eric ciotti je pense à bruno
retailleau je pense à gérard larcher
rachida dati enfin toutes ces personnes
là sont des personnes de compétences qui
ont déjà exercé des postes ministériels
et c'est avec eux qu'on doit
reconstruire la droite
[Musique]